you know his legacy is
one of so many wins and
so many accomplishments
and i've been a fan of his
and for a long time and enjoyed the few
times we've gotten to play i remember
when
i heard the news about him coming to the
nfc i thought this was a real
possibility
and i'm excited about the opportunity to
play against him one more time
[Music]
aaron rodgers getting ready to face tom
brady you know peter for a while we
thought we would see aaron rodgers and
tom brady cross paths in a super bowl
that almost happened six years ago today
at least that's when the packers would
have punched their ticket that's when
they blew that huge lead in seattle and
it was russell wilson versus tom brady
in super bowl 49. i'll take it in the
nfc championship game we prefer the
super bowl will take it in the nfc
championship game two great legacies two
of the greatest quarterbacks of all time
what more could you ask for in a
conference championship game oh wait
we've got patrick holmes and josh allen
the two best quarterbacks right now in
the nfl on the front end of their
careers and the two best of all time on
the back end of their careers i don't
think people really appreciate how
special this day is going to be
i totally agree mike i mean you know
first of all
we're talking about two of the best 10
quarterbacks who ever lived
are meeting
and it's one thing to say when the
history books look at this they'll say
two quarterbacks combined age of 80 how
great can it be
but
what i would counter by saying
is that you tell me
how many better years has aaron rodgers
had in his life
than this one and you know what it is
big goose egg how many better years has
tom brady had than this one one
so
you're looking at two guys
who even though
you know they average 40 years old
are in their primes
and you know no one can believe that no
one will believe that years from now
but
just as aaron rodgers is maybe the
smartest
person in the national football league
and i don't mean just about football i
mean alex trebek likes smart and just as
tom brady is the smartest person in the
nfl about whatever he puts into his body
okay
these are two guys who have figured out
how to be great at an advancing age and
they both still are i agree with you
it's amazing mike
this is the preliminary game
this is the first game
and uh you know normally you would say
oh my god put that where it'll get the
maximum crowd i think this will be one
of the great ratings in nfl history
for
that first uh you know conference
championship game
well and these two games peter
give the best evidence for what i've
been clamoring for for the past few
years which is sunday night monday night
conference championship games put them
both in prime time you've got 13 days
for the team that wins on monday night
to get ready for the super bowl you
can't say there's a disadvantage to that
you don't have to play both of those
games the same day but that that and
maybe this is the moment between that
and all the flexibility that's been
cooked into the schedule this year due
to the covet pandemic maybe the nfl
finally realizes these games don't have
to be back to back anymore we can do
sunday night monday night and the
numbers would be even more astronomical
especially with these two games
mike you know i think you're going to
see three new things
in the next television contract after
the negotiations are done
i think it'll probably be this off
season when the negotiations get done
maybe even one of them gets done before
then but i think you're gonna see three
new things number one
a lot of the mega cast ideas and
like the nickelodeon idea you got two
million people watching that one playoff
game on nickelodeon not a very good game
really but watching that playoff game on
nickelodeon saints bears that's going to
be part of it number two
i believe that there will be a monday
night wild card game in the next uh
in the next tv contract and number three
just like you said whether it be you
know sunday monday i think both of those
games
in the next tv contract at some point
will be in prime time
so the game that does start us off on
saturday or sunday afternoon excuse me
the packers taking on the
tampa bay buccaneers they got together
in week six just like the bills and
chiefs got together in week six ten
nothing packers
like the buccaneers had done for much of
the season fell behind but then the
buccaneers blew the doors off of the
green bay packers and one of the reasons
they did it peter the blitz the
relentless pressure on aaron rodgers
they were able to get to him unlike any
other team could all year and i think
for me especially playing this game in
green bay in the cold and they can talk
about how the cold's not an issue you
can talk about all you want how the call
is not an issue until you step out into
the cold and realize it's an issue but
the bucks are gonna need to replicate
that defensive performance if they're
gonna have a shot at holding aaron
rodgers and company in check
here's the funny thing about that last
game i look back at it this week mike
and you know it's amazing
the packers go up 10 to nothing early
and it really looks like it's going to
be a mismatch for about 10 or 15 minutes
and then rogers throws the interception
to jamel dean
demean dean returns it for the touchdown
and all of a sudden the onslaught is on
i think that over the course of the year
we have seen that tampa can be a
momentum
defense
you saw it in that game you saw it a
little bit on sunday against drew brees
and the saints
and that is what aaron rodgers i believe
has been studying this week and it's not
just oh don't make the big mistake no
duh but it is don't give that defense an
opportunity to get rolling
so i think it's going to be kind of a
big day for a lot of the play-action
passes a lot of the robert tunian
stuff
and and just
if if necessary control the clock and
instead of trying to beat the tampa
defense with the big strikes you know
just take little chunks at a time so
that defensive pressure doesn't ruin the
green bay game plan
and you made a great point about the
buccaneers being a momentum defense
because really it was
right on the brink of the saints
beginning the process of pulling away
they're up seven
jared cook catches the pass crosses
midfield and all of a sudden lightning
strikes antoine winfield rips the ball
out devin white play in the game keeps
it up
very cleanly we've seen so many
defensive players try to get a ball in
those situations they kick it all over
the place they don't know what they're
doing and eventually the offense
recovers it was a thing of beauty and
that turned everything and then
the defense after that just continued to
get better and better white had the
interception of alvin kamara there's a
great video floating around brees as
soon as he let go of the ball yelled for
alvin he knew he'd messed up and threw
the ball before alvin kamara was ready
for it that was the dagger really and uh
that's the key you have to if you're
aaron rodgers keep the buccaneers from
having that moment where
all of a sudden they
they believe their defense is going to
take over the game and and we saw the
saints hold it in check for you know two
quarters and and into the third but it
can turn quickly and i don't i think i
think you're absolutely right rogers
can't give them that opening to have
that defense turn it on like they did in
the second half against the saints
yeah and and mike the one other thing
you just said here here's why
when i think of the importance we talked
about ted thompson a minute ago now
let's talk for a second about the player
acquisition of jason light and the tampa
bay buccaneers
look at the biggest play in the game as
bruce arians told me after the game
aryan said that was the play of the game
the one you described antoine winfield
draft choice this season knocks the ball
out
devin white you know fifth overall pick
last season
recovers it advances it 20 yards or
whatever and that starts
the the turning of the momentum of the
game
don't forget the contributions
that the player acquisition people as
aryans told me after this game he goes
when's jason light going to get the
credit he deserves for this team not
only here but in putting the receiving
group together
at all at basically all fairly
reasonable prices
and so i think right now that's a time
to appreciate that and to know that both
of these teams have been putting uh put
in good position to compete on sunday
from the player acquisition sides of
their buildings uh you know we haven't
even mentioned lightnarian's recruiting
and signing tom brady
well and the team that light put
together
made it easier to get tom brady to pick
that team he's looking to go to a place
where the deck is stacked you start
looking at all the rosters you look at
who needs quarterbacks and that was the
no-brainer screaming out at him with all
those pass catchers with a defense that
was underrated and and over matched last
year when you have a starting
quarterback who throws 30 interceptions
in jameis winston
they were still seven and seven as
you've pointed out before going into the
final two games with jameis winston
having so many turnovers last year and
and uh yeah look it it it took a while
for them to hit their stride but they've
hit their stride and and i know it's not
going to be easy to win in green bay but
this buccaneers team right now and it
kind of you know mid-season we saw
flashes after this game week six against
the packers it's like you know they
could end up being pretty good we never
really knew who the best team in the nfc
was and we'll officially find out on
sunday but the buccaneers have a very
very good chance uh to pull this one off
because peter b it's you know tom brady
i think brings to the sideline to the
locker room to the field you know when
when you are living history the true
living legend
how does that not inspire the other guys
on the team
to reach his level or at least try to
reach his level
and and collectively become better than
what they individually would be i think
having a guy like brady around
especially for guys who aren't used to
it the packers players are used to aaron
rodgers this is still new for the
buccaneers players and i think that's a
huge huge factor
in in giving the bucks the lift that
they that they need to possibly pull
this off
mike in my column on monday i wrote
about uh devon white because i thought
he was the key to that game
and uh when i was talking to him after
the game one of the things that he said
was hey you know a couple of weeks ago a
few weeks ago i was really bummed out i
didn't make the pro bowl
and you know i told brady and brady said
to me hey d d
come on it's the pro bowl we're playing
for a bigger bowl than that
and it just
white basically
white basically said to me
in so many words that was a wake-up call
and you know let's think about what's
important when you're 22 years old and
you're coming in which is what devon
white is it's amazing
he's finished his second year in the nfl
and he's 22. but
things like the pro bowl are important
you soon realize that the pro bowl does
not amount to a hill of beans it's
absolutely meaningless other than in
contract clauses
but you know he wanted to make a pro
bowl that was a big thing to him and
brady just said hey listen think about
what's important please
and you know what there's another
element to this as well peter and i was
talking to somebody recently and and i i
can't name names but there's a thought
gurgling around the league that the
modern player
you know it used to be
football was one of your top three faith
family football in whatever order you
choose
for a lot of the guys now in the nfl
especially the younger guys the guys
under 30 the guys under 25 football is
not in the top three
and if you have a starting quarterback
for whom football frankly is number one
a clear number one you know maybe maybe
it's it's i don't know football and
family co number one for tom brady i
don't know i think there are times where
it's like family will be there after i
agree with you my family later right but
but when you have that guy who is there
to influence
this group of young guys for whom
football may not be in the top three
anymore or ever was that football was a
means to a different end
that's a powerful thing when you've got
that guy who isn't the coach
he's on the field he's in a helmet he's
part of the effort to win
that has a powerful you know your story
about devin white that's that's just a a
tangible example of what tom brady does
quit what do you who gives a
sorry i almost said the word about the
pro bowl who cares that but you need a
guy like that in your locker room to
send that message and not every team has
that peter
you know after the game when i was
talking aryans he he gave brady
tremendous credit
for
uh both helping him coach a lot of these
guys on offense which i saw firsthand in
august
coaching o.j howard all through her
practice um but the
the other thing that was so notable from
aryans is that he basically said he said
listen
i want tom brady to rub off on the guys
in this locker room and one of the ways
that brady does that is that kind of
story and
and another story that just really
sticks in my head when i talk to him
after the uh comeback against atlanta
and i said something to the effect of
don't you ever want to go out and like
have nine beers with your buddies
and he goes peter i've done that
you know i've done that it's fun and
maybe one day i'll do it again
but right now
this is fun and trying to you know make
my body basically perfect so that i can
do this for as long as i can that to me
is fun and so that is the kind of stuff
that antoine winfield jr is going to
want to hear that jamel dean is going to
want to hear that
mike evans doesn't want doesn't have to
hear it because he knows but you know
young guys scotty miller ronald jones
you know these are guys who tom brady is
going to be influencing for the rest of
their time in football no matter how
long brady plays for the bucks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports